hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
exploits have been around since the dawn
of video gaming some are simply amazing
some hilarious and some break the game
completely ranging from minor bugs and
glitches to monumental manipulations of
in game mechanics here are six video
game exploits we couldn't resist trying
be honest can you say you have never
tried any of these yourself by the way
these ideas have come from our discord
community so if you'd like to contribute
to future videos come join our
dysfunctional family I'll put a link
below let's start with the brilliance of
Skyrim which was released back in 2011
this open-world RPG will probably go
down as one of the greatest of all time
as I'm writing this it's about to be
released on virtual reality so hopefully
this exploit will still work for anyone
who is trying that diversion the main
gameplay loop of Skyrim revolves around
the skill tree and repetition of each
element to upgrade so for example to
level up block picking you need to pick
a ton of Lux well early on in the game
in fact just when you gain control of
your character which I'm sure you gave
an epic beard to follow hatva and once
he removes your bind pick up a sword and
beat the living [ __ ] out of him there
you go take a look around there should
be plenty of gear to choose from I'm
going to see if I can find something not
only do they survive but had bad doesn't
even mind and he will give you advice
whilst you're slicing him to pieces
you better get some gear
[Music]
see one of these chests of all yes in no
time at all you're single handed and
dual wielding levels will shoot up
making the game far easier in the
opening few hours this is also a great
method of relieving tension in your own
life and that's for mortgage repayments
and that's for the interest rates going
up and that's for Christmas songs coming
out in November this technique can be
exploited until you open the chest but
it's still possible to repeatedly butter
him until you finally reach Skyrim at
this point
oddvar will suddenly decide he's sick of
Yosh and will promptly put you in your
place
[Music]
exploiting single-player games is a
victimless crime
as you only limit your own experience of
a certain game but what about online
exploitations when Friday the 13th
released in May 2017 the horror
community rejoiced a game which puts you
in the boots of a psycho or a fear
filled councillor of Crystal Lake the
whole point of the game is to survive
Jason butts of course it's damn hard to
do as Jason can jump around the map and
kill everyone in quick succession this
led to some disgruntled people finding
exploits to ensure Jason couldn't catch
them one method used a bear trap to
glitch onto roofs and another user
crouch function or the t-bag button if
you are a Call of Duty player to glitch
through the walls into hidden spaces or
better yet the roof this meant unless a
Jason was lucky with his throwing knives
the cheaters would survive every game
and achieve high levels of XP this is
where the Hassan Friday the 13th
community came into its own they took it
upon themselves to help Jason by using
the glitch to find those tricksters and
either beating them to death or using a
shotgun to the face this one is from a
YouTube channel called relentless
remarked I salute you for your
dedication to tracking down these cheap
gun media were quickly to Putsch both
team killing and more importantly the
dreaded roof and wall bugs
[Music]
let's go back in time to 1992 and the
Super Nintendo and probably the greatest
2d RPG of all time
The Legend of Zelda a Link to the Past
okay let's just go back to the Super
Nintendo Mini instead the following
exploit works on both versions of the
game
most people will put 20 to 40 hours into
Link to the Past to experience the
entire story but for speedrunners an
exploit can make the games ending be
seen in just a few minutes and here's
how it's done after waking up and seeing
your uncle run into the night like a
madman make your way to the secret
entrance in the castle upon grabbing
your sword and shield take this route
and get this guards attention by holding
down the attack button and hitting a
nearby wall as he approaches put
yourself next to a wall and hold left
once he hits you you'll be in the wall
we can now run up a few screens along
the bottom and then straight up to the
end of the game now enjoy those credits
and the speedrun world record sadly this
glitch is not recognized as a real
record but hey print your own
certificate and know who will know you
are a dirty dirty dirty cheat except you
of course
[Music]
destiny is all about grind and repeating
the same level 50,000 times
but dammit I still like it the pinnacle
of each destiny title and expansion are
the raids in the original destiny we
exploited a Theon and a Theon eighth
beyond and pushed him off the edge of
the cliff then that was patched in fact
every single exploit gamers have found
in destiny has ultimately been patched
now in destiny 2 we have a glitch which
the developers are struggling to remove
it's the Calais glitch named after the
first area it was discovered in usually
at this point in the raid you are
fighting for your life and murder izing
more enemies than a Hollywood
blockbuster alternately with a bit of
timing the final boss encounter can look
more like this
so we just stand here this is so much
fun
we should do this more often to jube
with the system the last standing
guardian simply leaves the group as the
encounter is about to reset upon their
return all the doors are open and not a
single additional enemy will join the
fight ok so it completely destroys this
great encounter but doing this method is
all about how quick you can get this
precious loot
is it just my group or does someone
always punch the boss in the groin
repeatedly whatever floats your boat you
enjoy yourself pal it's all good
all the way back in early 2015 The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt was released to rave
reviews and open will quest have gone
with hundreds upon hundreds of items
making up the economy system new players
struggled to afford well struggle to
afford anything in the early stages as
Geralt was a bit skinned to say the
least
and finding ciri is an expensive affair
okay sidetracked come on to get round
this an exploit was discovered by
finding a field full of cattle and
slaughtering them all they could drop
their Pelt for Geralt to sell to
merchants what made the exploit even
better was by using the time passing
mechanic known as meditating this would
cause the cows to respawn and the
process could be repeated over and over
again completely breaking the game's
economy and giving the player an early
boost The Witcher threes developers CD
Projekt RED decided to patch the exploit
in a frankly brilliant way if the player
killed the cattle in white orchard three
times a great hulking level 27 charts
would come and wrecked them luckily this
beast was only a problem for low-level
players so I scored that beast
so if you're planning to exploit a CD
Projekt RED game then prepare to die
let's go back to Skyrim again and
probably the most used exploit in gaming
history I'll just say it the bucket head
thief it sounds ridiculous but for years
millions of us used a simple bucket or
basket to cover the eyes of a resident
in Skyrim and whilst they were asking
who turned out the lights
we stole everything we could my personal
fetish was to steal all drinking vessels
I called myself the mugger I was much
younger back then okay don't judge me
over time it finally got patched so what
started as a friendly bit of thievery
ended in a serial killer rampage I stole
enough Daedra hearts to make this
freaking stunning daedric armor and hope
said cheaters never prosper I'm living
the Skyrim dream whoo what a shame it's
all built on lies
[Music]
so there we have it six video game
exploits we couldn't resist trying we've
come a long way from cheat codes and
game genies and although video games
receive regular patches these days
exploits bugs and glitches are found
regularly a quick thank you to those on
discard who helped me with this list and
please consider subscribing if you
haven't already for more lists news and
general PlayStation tomfoolery I imagine
from PlayStation grenade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time so my
job is just to wait this is great
this is mmm just waiting okay I can do
that that's what you need me to do I'll
wait this this imagine if I was
live-streaming now this must be the most
awesome display of teamwork they've ever
seen in their lives hello and welcome to
PlayStation granade today standing
around and waiting mmm-hmm I can't take
this much longer
exploits aren't really that good of a
exploits I feel like I should make a
video about exploits after this in fact
yes I'm going to make a video about
exploits and I'll even put this in I'll
put this in medias just randomly talking
to myself whilst waiting for the team to
be ready on the callous glitch still on
my own anyone this is so much firm